مقاتلات عاصفه اليقظه الاكثر تطورا في
العالم تكشف ازمه سلاح الجو في كوريا
الشماليه
في استعراض عسكريين المتقدم حلق الطيران
الامريكيون والكوريون الجنوبيون في
مناوراتهم المشتركه في مقاتلات اكثرت 5
الخفيه المتطوره و طائرات حربيه الكترونيه
و طائرات اخرى لتزويد الوقود
مناورات المتقدمه دفعت للتساؤل عن حادث
صلاح الجو لدى كوريا الشماليه لتتحدث
تقارير عسكريه عن تهالف سلاح الجو لكوريا
يمتلك سلاح الجو لكوريا الشماليه 900
طائره مقاتله و 300 طائره شحن و 300
مروحيه وفقا لوكاله استخبارات الدفاع
الامريكيه حصلت عليها من الصين او الاتحاد
السوفيتي سابقا معظم تلك المقاتلات متوقف
في العنابر وخارج الخدمه
تقارير لوكاله استخبارات الدفاع الامريكيه
ذكرت ان كوريا الشماليه ليست لديها قدرته
على دفع ما يكفي من الوقود او تغطيه
تكاليف الصيانه او تدريب الطيارين بشكل
صحيح فالطيارون يحلقون ما بين خمسه عشره
الى 25 ساعه طيران سنويا اي اقل بكثير من
المتوسط المعروف في صفوف القوات الجويه
الامريكيه والكوريه الجنوبيه
ايضا ان السبب تاخر السلاح الجو الكوري
الشمالي كان وراءه انهيار الاتحاد
السوفيتي الذي كان مصدر رئيسا للدعم
المالي والعسكري فضلا عن العقوبات التي
فرضت على كوريا الشماليه بسبب برامجها
لانتاج الصواريخ والاسلحه النوويه ما زاد
من صعوبه ايجاد موارد لتطوير وتحديث
سلاحها ملوك الشيخ العربي
[موسيقى]